along a long stretch of California's
scenic Pacific Coast Highway
it is now bird under a colossal mudslide
more than a million tons of rock and
dirt tumbled down a hillside south of
Monterey last weekend the highway could
be closed for months material shows us
how the natural roadblock is affecting
coastal communities from the air it
looks like an entire mountainside was
sheared off what had been a 1500 foot
section of the Pacific Coast Highway is
now buried under 40 feet of dirt and
debris there were no reports of deaths
or injuries this is what the seashore
looked like before the ground gave way
Saturday night the new shoreline now
extends 250 feet further out
and although tourists around the world
are drawn to this rugged coast for its
famed natural beauty the seaside
addition is more likely to drive them
away
the landslide has further isolated the
monks and staff at the new Kemal Dooley
Hermitage a monastery south of Big Sur
most of our income is generated through
hospitality through inviting guests to
come here and stay if they can't get
here then we don't have an income source
some 50 miles of the Pacific Coast
Highway are now closed sandwiched
between landslides to the south and a
bridge failure to the north that bridge
was badly damaged by the severe storms
that battered California this winter it
was torn down last month those heavy
rains also left the area vulnerable to
landslides the most heartbreaking part
of the bridge going down and the
mudslides further south on highway 1 has
been the impact on the workers the
highway is the main artery for coastal
communities here state transportation
officials say they don't know winner
will completely reopen the ground around
Saturday's slide is still unstable
restaurant owner Kirk Gathol hopes
hungry tourists will file through his
doors again soon we've been in business
for 68 years we are always looking at
the long view for CBS this morning
midday of young Los Angeles